in this video we're going to be talking
about how you can write electron
configurations using noble gas notation
and to be more specific in this video
we're also going to be focusing on
examples using main group elements so
we're doing that because the transition
metals right here and the lanthanides
are a little bit more complicated so we
won't be doing that in this particular
video so the rule for writing the noble
gas notation for something is pretty
simple it is you take the noble gas
immediately preceding your atom or ion
so what do I mean by immediately
preceding that means we want the noble
gas that comes right before it so you go
up a row and then you go over to here
where the noble gases live and you put
that in brackets and then you write your
other electrons and you write your other
electrons using the same notation that
you normally write electron
configurations in if you don't remember
what that is we'll go through a couple
examples right now so hopefully it will
become more clear so before we get
started I'm just gonna remind you why we
call the noble gases noble and that is
because they have a full octet of
electrons and so since they have a full
octet they're not very reactive they
have all of the electrons they want and
as a result you will see in chemistry
that a lot of chemistry chemical
reactions will be driven by other non
noble gases trying to get a full octet
so the first example we're going to talk
about and write the configuration for is
silicon silicon is right below carbon in
the periodic table
and we can write its full electron
configuration just for comparison so if
we start up here with hydrogen silicon
has the electron configuration 1s2 2s2
2p6 so as a reminder these are RS
electrons because they're in s orbitals
these are our P electrons because there
are P orbitals and then once we're
through our 2p 6 electron so you go to 3
s 2 and we have two more electrons so
it's 3 P 2 so that's the electron
configuration for silicon now we can
write it out using noble gas notation
and compare so the noble gas immediately
preceding silicon if we go up a row and
then move over we see that it's neon so
we write neon in brackets and then the
other electrons are the ones that come
after neon so we go down and the
electrons that aren't included and neon
would be our 3 s 2 electrons right here
and the 3 P 2 electrons so if we compare
these two ways of writing our electron
configuration you can see that these
electrons right here so everything up to
3 s 2 3 P 2 that gives us the electron
configuration for neon and so we don't
have to write that we just write neon
and assume that whoever is reading it
knows what the left Ron configuration
for neon is the other thing you might
notice is that these other electrons
here that we wrote outside of the
brackets these are our valence electrons
so writing your electron configuration
this way using notebook
notation makes it really obvious where
your valence electrons are and what kind
they are so that's helpful we are going
to go through one more example and that
will be calcium so calcium is over here
and so we're not going to write the full
electron configuration this time we're
just going to write the noble gas
notation so calcium the noble gas
immediately preceding it we go up a row
and then over and we see that the noble
gases are gone so we rewrite argon in
our brackets and then what electrons are
not in argon so we move down and we see
that we have our 4s electrons and we
have two of them so this is the noble
gas configuration for calcium so does
calcium have a full octet and we know
that these are the valence electrons and
we also know that if it did have a full
octet it would actually already have a
noble gas configuration so it would
either have Krypton or argon and in this
case it turns out that calcium prefers
to lose two electrons as opposed to
gaining a bunch it would be gaining 10
plus 6 so lose two electrons and when
calcium loses two electrons it becomes
kepta calcium 2 plus cation and then we
can write the electron configuration
really short or it'll be really short
because we know it's gonna lose these
two valence electrons and then it will
have the electron configuration which is
just the same as argon and we can tell
really easily looking at this that
calcium 2 plus has a full octet
so one of the many pros of writing
things in noble gas notation besides the
fact that it you know makes your hand
less tired is that it makes it really
easy to see where your valence electrons
are and whether or not your ion or atom
has a full octet